benvenuti il nuovissimo giorno di oggi è
un nuovo video all
perché insomma con l'autunno l'arrivo
insomma dei primi freddi
ho comprato delle cosine nuove volevo
farvele vedere vi avviso già che non
sono tantissime cose ma sono super super
super top quindi la qualità prima di
tutto oltre alla sobrietà ovviamente
iniziamo
ok forse sace da lui che privano
bellissimo sacchetto adesso è aperto
danno subito bryce lawrence ho preso
questo è fantastico maglioncino super
super carino per l'inverno questo colore
così candido questo colore da baita e di
alta montagna e di brulè
rimaniamo intermodalità e montagna
perché ho preso anche queste fantastiche
morbidissimo golfo nei che rimane aperto
aspetti di quelli che si possono
incrociare che siete come un bel
cinturone insomma con un jeans con un
leggins fa la sua figura e soprattutto
tiene molto caldo d'inverno adoro il
bianco poi avevo bisogno di una bella
felpa da tutti i giorni e ho preso
questa quindi ligio che si abbina a
tutto poi col nero soprattutto io che
sono sempre tutto quasi sempre total
black comoda pratica sempre verde e per
finire in bellezza una note di barbie
una nota di paris hilton una nota di
peppa pig ecco il mio vicino preferito
ovviamente però usa morbidina carino
colore supermarina quindi approvato
andiamo avanti con mag che è un bene che
io adoro a d'oro avevo già comprato una
giacca invernale l'anno scorso l'aveva
messa in un video quella che mi aveva
regalato mio padre a natale ma ricordate
è corali mag
anche questa volta ho comprato una
giacca ma una giacca un po diversa
questa infatti è un chiodo di pelle
molto bike è molto rock and roll e io lo
amo l'avete già visto lo so che lo
ricordate in una foto che ho postato
ultimamente su instagram è infatti tanti
di voi bianchissima e cerca dura impresa
l'ho presa da mai l'ho amata fin dal
primo istante sta bene con tutto col
janis con la gonna col vestito e
morbidissima ed è diventata la mia nuova
giacca della vita un centrale però mai
più sempre da mai ho preso questo
vestitino non l'avevo ancora scartato
per farlo online davanti a voi
immaginate quanto siete importanti e un
abito che a parte mi sta molto bene ma
poi io lo trovo super super super carino
super classico ma con quel tocco di
stile con quel tocco di signorina
rottermeier no a parte gli scherzi sta
veramente bene addosso è uno di quei
vestiti che li vedi appesi si carino
però lo provi mio lo voglio cucito
addosso quindi il nostro mito preso non
vedo l'ora di indossarlo e di fare
qualche scatto che potrete vedere sul
mister non mi segui su instagram è
arrivato momento di seguirmi continuiamo
con un completo composto da gonna e
lupetto maglia a collo alto da dovete
sapere che io d'inverno vivo con le
maglie a collo alto questa è
un'eccezione perché dovevo girare il
video ma nella mia quotidianità
d'inverno l'inverno per me leggings o
jeans e collo alto e maglioncino fine di
giorno poi di sera è la sobrietà prima
di tutto di giorno un po più contenuta
quindi ho preso questa lupetto che mi
piace un sacco poi quest'anno se ne
vedono tantissime così è abbinato socio
questo gol ma forse di velluto rosa
io trovo questo completo veramente
veramente stiloso veramente veramente
pretty little liars
in particolare aria chiusa parentesi
allora questo
sempre di magma non c'è dentro altra
roba di magma altre cosine che ho
comprato che ho cliccato qui dentro
perché mi serviva una busta per il video
ovviamente
partiamo con questo abito di other
stories un altro negozio che io adoro
ecco a prima vista potrebbe sembrare ok
una roba trash una roba da flinstones in
particolare dilma cristo ma è un altro
sito come quello di masche addosso e
soprattutto abbinato al chiodo nuovo di
pelle con uno stivale alto di quelli che
vanno adesso sopra il ginocchio è 11
cioè io non vedo l'ora di avere una
serata un po rock un po grintosa per
indossare questo outfit che perfetto jal
outfit non è ancora capito se una serata
grintosa o rock and roll ma capiterà non
si sa ma poi è l'anno dei baschi dei
cappellini
ne ho già 18 v o meno un logo preso
l'anno scorso rosso ve lo ricorderete
tanti voi mi hanno detto molto stile
super mario ma il piaceva un sacco
e infatti voi che avete criticato
quest'anno se dovete comprarlo al basco
perché all'ultimo grido io perché so
anche questo da h m pagato pochissimo e
lo trovo top
ovviamente si abbina benissimo con tutti
i miei outfit total black e quindi l'ho
detto tutti i giorni praticamente l'uomo
da zara invece ho preso questo
maglioncino questo punto sono abbastanza
rock e dom sto stupendo dimesso in rosa
questo il maglioncino con questo
dettaglio come li possiamo definire dei
rombi dei quadratini argentati i punti
luce mi suggerisce la regia grazie molto
molto carino molto stiloso e molto rock
quindi cosa sta succedendo a marina
dovevi dire qualcosa
concludiamo con
delle scarpe delle scarpe che volevo da
tantissimo ma non avevo mai comprato
solo data al negozio li ho provate e
pantofole cioè quando io provo una
scarpa e la sento una pantofola la
compra perché per me la comodità prima
di tutto anche la società ovviamente e
soprattutto in inverno sono freddolosi
stima quindi potevo non avere nel mio
armadio delle scarpe nella mia scarpiera
i signori ag non potevo non averli ma
soprattutto secondo voi di che colore io
presi vediamo un po se li conoscete blu
azzurri verdi arancioni
ma no li ho presi nelli ovviamente ma
con un piccolo dettaglio luce anche qui
vedete che ritorna questa circolarità
del dettaglio luce è praticamente una
spilla con degli swarovski attaccati e
questa è la terza la mia preferita
perché quello cassano mi piace tanto
come stava quello alto mi smorzato un po
la gamba che sono solo altissima come vi
dicevo prima io d'inverno con cielo
soprattutto per quanto riguarda le
estremità mani piedi e naso mi si
congelano diventano dei pezzi di
ghiaccio e quindi per me è necessario
avere delle scarpe che mi scaldino bene
il piede e queste ragazzi non ce ne sono
le scarpe gli stivaletti più caldi che
potete trovare in cornice colazione io
li amo non vedo l'ora di utilizzarli e
per adesso non fa ancora così tanto
freddo ma secondo me ci stiamo
avvicinando è tra due settimane si gela
con questo abbiamo chiuso il video
autunnale come avete visto non ho
comprato tantissima roba ma ho preso
delle cosine molto carine molto top
molto stilose molto rock and roll per il
mio autunno e ovviamente restate
connessi per che prossimamente sarà nel
loro l'invernale ovviamente è lì proprio
vabbè non vi dico inter che già qualche
idea sui miei acquisti invernali
lo scoprirete solo vivendo e guardando
inter mio vizio come al solito vi
ricordo se non avete affermato di
iscrivervi al mio canale e di cliccare
sulla campanella che trovate vicino al
tasso di iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati sui nei video sui miei video
all sui miei video nei camp su tutto e
soprattutto per essere i primi a
commentare
ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social quindi su instagram
facebook e tic toc
io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo video
[Musica]